in the 1930s
right this is a fantastic story and
nobody knows about it
with the rise of nationalist
socialist ideology in germany
they come to the united states we had a
guy by the name of fritz kuhn
k-u-h-n all right he declares himself as
the hitler
of america and he starts to rally
um and
bring together the recent immigrants
that came post world war one after the
defeat of the kaiser wilhelm
we had a tremendous amount of germans
that came to the united states
north new jersey was originally a large
german population we had beer gardens
the brit they called themselves the
brown shirts all right
brown shirts the brown shirts brown
shirts all right and it was called the
bund
bund which means the organization in
in german and they would start beating
up on jews
my father was part of a an organization
called the minutemen
the minute men were all under the
supervision all under the administration
of longies willman
and they formed an organization called
the minutemen
which in a minute's notice were just
like in the revolutionary war
you would have men available in a matter
of a minute to go fight the british
our guys went to fight the american nazi
party
there's a book called the the the nazis
in newark written by a
dear friend of mine warren grover that
relates
exactly every time that the nazis would
meet
our guys would go in and beat the [ __ ]
out of these nazi bastards
all right and this went on throughout
the entire 1930s
mariolansky took on the nazis in
yorkville up on uh
first avenue and 86th street um
beat the [ __ ] out of him up there it
went on in
in minneapolis in chicago
the fine beat the [ __ ] out of him what
does that mean what does beat the [ __ ]
out of our guys would go in with with
baseball bats they'd go in with monkey
wrenches with
brass knuckles stink bombs to throw into
the place so when they come running out
our guys were waiting there all right
rising anti-semitism today people say
oh my god you know but in that time
jews were responding to it the the mob
in minneapolis
dave berman um
herman pastor sam duran
wherever the the the silver shirts
another
anti-semitic organization would meet our
guys were there
to beat the [ __ ] out of them all right
in chicago
there was a very famous prize fighter
triple crown champion hero at
guadalcanal by the name of
barney ross very great american hero
and fought at guadalcanal when he was in
his 30s
um he was a hero at guadalcanal
in the time of the nazis uh
they beat up they fought the
anti-semites at the jew haters in
chicago
one of the guys that were that fought
together with barney ross was jacob
rubenstein some people said
who the hell was jacob robenstein so let
me make it easy for you
jack ruby there's a son of a [ __ ] jack
roby
yeah he was he was a jewish hero all
right
a bit of a new crazy guy but uh he was a
jewish hero
jack ruby he fought together with with
all the jews to
defend against anti-semite so if you
like the sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye